[Musik]
es liegt Schnee in der Luft in Hintertux
es hat geschneit endlich
sogar im Tal ist es nun weiß
Winterwunderland wie es sein soll
sichtlich erleichtert ist der Chef vom
Tourismusverband
die Schneelage an sich hat sich
natürlich deutlich verbessert mit dem
Neuschnee was man kriegt damit diese 40
50 cm ganz oben am Berg und was
natürlich
die Schönste am Ganzen ist dass man
einfach wieder diese Winterlandschaft
hat eine Winterlandschaft die für den
Skitourismus nicht nur
Geschäftsgrundlage ist so weiß es
Hermann Erler sondern auch ein
Sicherheitsfaktor denn Schnee kann viel
Unvermögen und selbst Überschätzung
abpuffern
und vor ein paar Tagen fehlte das
Hintertux in den Weihnachtsferien
auf eisiger Piste geriet eine
Skifahrerin ins rutschen sie durchbrach
den Sicherheitszaun und schlug dann
ungebremst gegen diesen Baum
für sie kam jede Hilfe zu spät
zwei weitere Skifahrerinnen verletzten
sich hier am gleichen Tag schwer hätte
die Piste gesperrt werden müssen die
Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt nun wegen
fahrlässiger Tötung
[Musik]
im laufenden Verfahren zur Piste
schwarze Pfanne will sich kein
Betroffener äußern Hermann Erler meint
auch Skifahrer hätten eine Verantwortung
und die Beschaffenheit der Piste sei
eben immer mal anders
es ist immer die Frage hat man viel
Naturschnee wie sind die Temperaturen
wie viel wie viel Kunst Schnee ist da
und so weiter also das hat sind viele
viele Faktoren die natürlich auch auf
gebissen Verhältnisse Einfluss haben
doch die Saison startet ungewöhn Reich
waren diese Bilder gehen um die Welt und
ebenso die Nachrichten über schwere
Unfälle wegen schwieriger
Pistenverhältnisse
13 Pisten tote bis zum Jahreswechsel
zählt Österreich so viele wie seit
Jahren nicht
in der Uniklinik Innsbruck versorgen sie
nicht mehr aber schwerere Unfälle
erzählt dr Aurora
kürzlich waren an einem Tag neun von elf
schockräumen belegt mit
lebensgefährlichen schieferletzungen er
führt eine traurige Statistik
und mir für die gesamte Skisaison bis
Ostern rein von Alpinski haben wir am
meisten zu 8 bis 9 Querschnittsgelähmte
und mittlerweile haben wir bis jetzt
schon fünf
es sind viele Faktoren die zu solchen
Unfällen führen
Selbstüberschätzung gehört auch dazu
sagt er aber die Häufung der Fälle in
schneearme Zeit macht ihn nachdenklich
das macht uns natürlich schon ein
Problem wenn wir so ein Schneeband haben
und links und rechts nur noch grün
würden Sie sagen der Klimawandel macht
das Skifahren gefährlicher ich glaube
Klimawandel wird merken dass in allen
Regionen und in allen Bereichen
wir haben uns schon überlegt ob das
nicht besser wäre die schieße so nach
hinten noch zu verlegen aber genau das
wollen wieder Gäste noch Touristiker
auch sie fällt in Tirol ist ausgebucht
in den Ferien es gibt hier einen Bahnhof
trotzdem reisen die meisten mit dem Auto
im CO2 Fußabdruck pro Tag macht die
Anreise mit dem Auto den größten Anteil
aus gefolgt von Unterkunft und dem
CO2-Ausstoß für Skifahrer Aktivitäten
Skiurlauber sind nicht nur Opfer im
Klimawandel sondern auch Täter der
Schnee hat sich nach dem Urlaubskalender
zu richten auch wenn bei manchen das
klimagerissen nackt
also es ist ein bisschen gruselig
ehrlich gesagt wir haben auch Freunde
gefragt ob die mitfahren wollen wir
haben das relativ spontan gebucht die
haben gesagt hey lohnt sich das denn
eigentlich noch dass die Kinder
Skifahren lernen wer weiß wie lang ist
das überhaupt noch gibt also man guckt
sich das schon an ich kann ich habe
jetzt keine Zahlen im Kopf oder hat mich
nicht damit beschäftigt was das jetzt an
Energie kostet das alles künstlich
herzustellen aber wenn man das mal sieht
und dann vergleiche sieht wird einem
dann natürlich auch anders
circa vier Euro kostet ein Kubikmeter
Schnee eine kostbare flüchtige Ware und
sie ist Michael rothleitners Geschäft
erforscht und berät Skigebiete die
besser und Energie sparender beschneid
werden kann da habe sich einiges getan
zeigt er er lässt eine alte und eine
neue Kanone laufen und zeigt uns dann
den Stromverbrauch weniger ist die
Hälfte von der anderen Maschine das ist
die Entwicklung im Wesentlichen der
letzten 20 Jahre
das was wir mit der Beschreibung ja vor
allem tun können ist eine verlässlichen
Saison Beginn sicherstellen dass der
gastgrundbuchen
seinen Koch einstellen bis zu 80% der
Pisten Österreichs werden beschneid aber
auch den Kunstschnee setzen die warmen
Winter zu
langfristig wird Skifahren nur auf
Pisten möglich sein die hoch und kalt
genug Liegen
die Klimakiller seien aber nicht die
Schneekanonen das wüssten die elbler wie
er sie nennt sie brachten nur das was
die Gäste wollen den Schnee
greift ihr diese technische Beschneiung
gerne an um zu zeigen dass die Älpler
immer noch nicht kapiert haben dass der
Winter vorbei ist dem wird nicht so sein
sondern der Winter wird das am Ende des
Jahrhunderts auch noch da sein aber sie
sind die Leidtragenden eigentlich einer
mutlosen Klimapolitik nicht nur
leidtragender gibt dazu natürlich sind
sie da so wie jeder von uns Täter ist
also ich glaube dass wir Europäer die
Nordamerikaner auch uns einfach im
Klaren sein müssen dass unser
Energieverbrauch
einfach nicht akzeptabel ist
doch sie wollen den Krisen davon fahren
für ein paar Tage der Schneemangel ist
nun vergessen und dann Unfälle mag auch
keiner mehr denken doch der Schnee wird
wieder schmelzen die Klimakrise bleibt